Donald Trump seems to believe Vladimir
Putin over our own intelligence agencies
although he's now trying to sort of
distance himself from that statement
while still saying that he believes
Vladimir Putin it's a very weird thing
and this happened during Donald Trump's
trip to Asia we've been covering his
trip he had that bizarre stop in Japan
he had that strange foreign policy
speech in South Korea and then he had a
meeting with Russian President Vladimir
Putin in Vietnam that was sort of
unusual to say the least and as you know
the position of American intelligence
agencies has been for a very long time
now that Russia interfered in the 2016
election with the goal of helping Donald
Trump defeat Hillary Clinton right that
that's been the the consensus opinion of
American intelligence ease Putin has
previously and again to trump in Vietnam
just a couple of days ago said we didn't
medal and Trump apparently believes
Vladimir Putin here's a transcript from
Trump's conversation with a reporter
about this a reporter said did Russia's
attempt to meddle in u.s. elections come
up in the conversations with Putin of
course Trump said he said he didn't
meddle he said he didn't meddle I asked
him again you can only ask so many times
and the reporter said today and Trump
said I just asked him again
he said he absolutely did not meddle in
our election he did not do what they are
saying he did and the reporter said on
election meddling did you ask him the
question and Trump said every time he
sees me he says I didn't do that and I
really believe that when he tells me
that he means it there are some really
specific questions that need asking
right like for example how do you know
President Trump
whether you should believe a hostile
foreign leader over your own
intelligence assessments or can you tell
us other times where you take the word
of a foreign leader over our
intelligence agencies is this the only
time or do you do it other times as well
what do you believe has made our
intelligence agencies so untrustworthy
if that's what you believe that they are
and of course after the fact when an
understandable amount of chaos started
when Trump said hey I basically believe
Putin despite what our intelligence
agencies have said
Trump tried to distance himself from
these comments which is a known strategy
for Trump right you say something if
people react negatively you deny ever
having said it and we have a quote from
Donald Trump at a news conference with
the Vietnamese president where he said
as to whether I believe it or not I'm
with our agencies especially as constant
as currently constituted as currently
led by fine people I believe very much
in our intelligence agencies now this is
such a weasel way of getting out of this
what on earth is that about you might be
saying what he has cut as as constituted
currently Trump is basically going back
to his prior claims that the assessments
before from our intelligence agencies
couldn't be believed because you had
what he described as political hacks
running our Intel and Trump actually
said during this conversation with the
reporters a few days ago
so you look at it I mean you have former
CIA director John Brennan you have
former Director of National Intelligence
James clapper and you have former FBI
director Jim Comey Comey is proven now
to be a liar and he is proven now to be
a leaker so you look at that and you
have President Putin very strongly
vehemently says he had nothing to do
with them so he's basically saying what
he says about every American agency
right the Congressional Budget Office or
the Bureau of Labor Statistics whoever
under Obama when they said anything
positive about Obama's economy
definitely couldn't be trusted under
Trump well if they say good things about
Trump's economy then they can be trusted
if they say bad things then it's
political hackery it's the exact same
thing and I know that this isn't proof
that Donald Trump is compromised but
this is exactly how a president that is
compromised by Russia would be acting
right to take their word over his own
intelligence agencies but then to say
that now that I've taken over the
intelligence agencies and my people are
there instead of the previous people
they can be trusted and of course this
goes to a total lack of understanding of
how these intelligence agencies work
right James clapper John Brennan these
are people with very long careers that
involve working for both Democrats and
Republicans
both of those individuals considered to
be trustworthy and respectable and not
political hacks by both Republican and
Democratic administrations and the mere
idea that Trump is floating here the
politicization of our intelligence
agencies is so problematic and of course
it's mostly problematic because he seems
to although he's kind of trying to
backtrack believe flat amir putin over
the best assessments the consensus
assessments of multiple american
intelligence agencies that yes happened
during the transition period between
President Barack Obama and President
Donald Trump scary scary stuff the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad